talking to a s-day Adventist and an
Israelite who referred me to a a passage
that I was familiar with when they
talked about you have to keep the law
and faith in Jesus and they went to uh
Revelation 14 and12 saying that you have
to keep the law and Faith for salvation
yeah they're saying the Commandments but
okay when they quote it what
Commandments are they saying You must
keep right well they're saying that I
gotta keep um the Sabbath feast days uh
don't eat certain foods okay see they're
lying to you the Commandments that you
keep are the
Commandments the Lord Jesus Christ gave
through his Apostles and yet they took
that statement of Revelation which is
now after the revelation of Jesus Christ
after Christ has entered the world after
he died and rose again after he ascended
into glory after he sent out the
apostles and the power of the spirit to
issue Commandments to churches and those
are the Commandments we keep they took
that statement and then tried to tie it
with the law of Moses and we keep the
law of Moses as given through Moses as
opposed to the law of Jesus and how
Jesus explains the LA of Moses so let me
show you how to school them you ready
yes sir go to Matthew 28 19-
okay okay I'm ready read it for me okay
and it says go therefore and Make
Disciples of all Nations baptizing them
in the name of the father and of the son
and of the Holy Spirit teaching them to
to observe all that I have commanded you
and behold I Am With You Always to the
End of the Age so what are the
Commandments you are to
observe the Commandments that um he's
taught them all right now go to John 14
and read 15 to 24 John 14 15-
14 John Chapter 14 verse 15 15 and
24 okay it says if you love me keep my
Commandments you my Commandments keep
who if you love yeah if you love me you
will keep my commandments so what
Commandments do you think John who wrote
the Gospel in Revelation had in mind in
Revelation right the Commandments that
Christ was telling them to keep all
right now keep reading to 24 keep
reading okay uh uh verse 15 if you I'm
sorry verse 16 and I will ask the father
and he will give you in another helper
to be with you forever even the spirit
of Truth whom the world cannot receive
because it neither sees him nor knows
him you know him for he dwells with you
and will be in you I will not leave you
as orphans I will come to you yet a
little while and the world will see me
no more but you will see me because I
live you also will live and that day you
will know that I am in the father I am
in my father and you in me and I in you
whoever has my Commandments and keeps
them my Commandments
huh the Moses Commandments or my
Commandments yes Whoever has my
Commandments and keeps them not just
pays lip service what
happens he it is who loves me and he who
loves me Will Be Loved by my father and
I will love him and manifest myself to
him wow okay right now keep reading all
the way to 24 okay um Judas not scariot
said to him Lord how is it that you will
manifest yourself to us and not to the
world Jesus answered him if anyone loves
me he will keep my word and my father
will love him and we will come to him
and make our home with him whoever does
not love me does not keep my words and
the word that you hear is not mine but
the fathers who sent me oh okay now did
you catch what he just said he just said
you love me you'll keep my Commandments
and if you keep my Commandments my
promise to you is my father and I will
live with you
spiritually walk with you oversee your
life protect you nourish you guide you
and preserve you forever if you keep my
Commandments my words which the father
gave me to give to you then this is our
promise but did he say whoever keeps the
Commandments of Moses or my Commandments
that the father gave me to give to you
keep them Father and I and the spirit
because he mentioned the holy spirit
being in them all all three persons of
the godhead the father son Spirit we
will personally dwell with every one of
you to oversee your life to preserve you
to guide you to love you to nourish you
to preserve you from all harm so you
can't quote Revelation 14:12 to say that
those who keep the Commandments are the
ones who are saved and those
Commandments are the law of Moses no
because John is the one who wrote the
Gospel of John and he's the one who
recorded the words of Jesus and Jesus
told John to tell others it's my
commands you keep and you follow and you
obey right right let me give you a few
more references that you're under the
law of Christ not the law of Moses are
you ready yes I'm um I'm just noting
this really quickly if that's okay take
your time yeah and when you note that
let me know because I'm G to show you
now the New Testament says the New
Testament you're under the law of Christ
so the way I know which parts of the law
of Moses are binding on me and which
parts I've been freed from is reading
the New Testament seeing what Jesus and
the inspired Apostles and the writers of
the New Testament tell me which parts of
the Old Testament have been fulfilled in
Christ so that I don't follow them the
way they were given to Moses because
Jesus fulfilled them I now follow the
reality Jesus Christ not the Shadow and
which parts of LA Moses are still
binding on me so that's why they can
never give you in the New Testament you
have to keep Sabbath but anyway that's
another point now go to 1 Corinthians
9:23
9:23 9 and 23 okay I'm here brother read
it for
me I do it all for the sake of the
Gospel that I might share with them and
his Blessing do you not know that in the
race all the runners run but only one
receives the prize so run that you may
obtain hold on my friend I just got a
brain
freeze hold
on I got a brain freeze that's First
Corinthians 9:24-27 can you read for me
1 Corinthians
9:21 21 sorry man I got a brain freeze
you know why because we're thinking John
24 give me it's okay brother you still
perfect closest thing I'm better I'm
more perfect than uh Propet Google it's
1th 9:21 because 23 is the ending of
that discussion
23 ends the point he makes in verse 19
but it's 21 so hey technically I'm all
good it's all in the hood all right go
ahead 21 all right you want start at
verse 21 no just read 21 yeah that's it
okay okay um verse 21 to those outside
the law I became as one outside the law
not being outside the law of God but
under the law of Christ so Paul is under
whose
law sorry say it again brother Paul is
under whose law whose law does Paul obey
um the law of Christ not the law of
Moses right then a final one Galatians 6
verse2 bear one another's burdens and so
fulfill the law of Christ so how many
more verses do I need to show you that
the Commandments that Christians follow
the law that Christians submit to are
the commandments of Jesus Christ Our
Lord the law of Jesus Christ as revealed
by Christ on Earth and through his
Apostles and their companions by the
spirit right I mean you said something I
think you said it last night as a matter
of fact when uh it was a guy he was
dealing with some muhammadans or
something like that and he was all like
just because you give them the arguments
you're not going to you know convince
them to you know repent and believe the
gospel even Jesus was you know preaching
to the people and he didn't save
everybody so you know I took that and
notated that because as much as I I see
why Jesus wept over him and how you you
know so often do when you you get
emotional you talk about the goodness of
Christ and how he saved just sa if we
just think about our own salvation he
saved me like why you know what I mean
Hallelujah like and that's the you you
don't love them more than God does and
you don't have more compassion than God
does and when Jesus walked this Earth
not everyone got saved even though they
saw Jesus heard Jesus even Judas walked
with Jesus saw the love of Jesus
compassion of Jesus the power of Jesus
the glory of Jesus and did miracles in
Jesus name and he still betrayed Jesus
for 30 pieces of
silver right right so do you think
you're going to do a better job than
your lord and
savior not even can't even come close at
all now you have any other one questions
my brother yeah the last one is I'm
sorry Isaiah 66 And1 17 that's the last
one s yes yeah I know they we read it so
people know what they're quoting okay
let me go to let me let me go to it
right quick brother yeah I know they're
gonna quot they're saying that in the
age to come that they'll even keep his
Sabbath
right right and then it talks about
eating swine flesh
all right read it though read Isaiah
6617 read that okay it says uh Isaiah
6617 says Those Who sanctify and purify
themselves to go into the gardens
following one in the midst eating pigs
flesh and the Abomination and M shall
come to an end together declares the
Lord yeah now you know why whoever
quotes shows there in
ignoramus this is talking about who
shall inherit eternal life that's the
age to come
right yes sir now from the perspective
of Isaiah from the time of Isaiah Isaiah
is now being told by God to reveal to
the Covenant people do you want to make
sure that you enter into the life of the
age to come yes well those who break his
Covenant and their stipulations will be
cut off so now you have to look at it in
its historical context could you be a
god-fearer and break the commands of God
given to you at that
time I guess I guess you could but then
answer well no no no no no you're not
hearing me how can you be a godfear and
break his commands and ignore them oh at
that time no no no no you're right no so
if you are living at the time of
Isaiah and Isaiah tells you here is the
way to Salvation here's the path to
obtain the life in the age of to come
you need to keep Covenant faithfulness
because if you willfully break the
Covenant then that means you defy God
you're opposing God you're sin against
God you're an evil doer who be cut off
so my question again in light of what I
just said in the historical context of
Isaiah a god-fearer would be someone who
kept the Covenant
right right ABS what
covenant What Covenant time okay so it
only makes sense that Isaiah would say
to those living under that Covenant hey
you eat mice and Swine that means you
are willfully defiling the Covenant
breaking it showing that you're a
wicked sinner who is willfully defying
God so your judgment will be
destruction that makes sense okay so in
the context it makes sense that I'm
talking to people you here's God's
covenant here's his commands when you
break his command and eat what he tells
you not to eat that means you're telling
God I don't care for your commands I
don't care for you you are now a willful
transgressor defiantly rebelling against
God and opposing him so you will be
destroyed in the age to
come how else do you want go ahead
sirad no that it just when you said that
it just went enough because you know
that's how they can prove their
faithfulness to God by keeping the law
at that time that's what he's saying so
at that time I want you to get it kenth
at that time keeping law meaning don't
eat this eat that so if I decided to eat
whatever I want am I keeping Covenant
faithfulness no not at all so then what
will be the result for me in the life to
come in the age to
come I'm I'm condemned okay that's what
Isaiah's saying but the same Isaiah also
told the Covenant people expect God's
servant to come and his law you will
follow and all the nations will follow
his law and he uses the word t in Hebrew
go to Isaiah 42: 1
and4 okay hold on brother let me go to
it I'm sorry I got to exit out the
screen sorry
brother all right Isaiah 42 I'm sorry
said what was it Isaiah 42 veres 1 or4
Isaiah 42 ver 1-4 but now let me repeat
the same Isaiah prophesied the servant
of God would come and everyone Jews and
all the nations would then obey the law
of the servant and Hebrew is Torah the
Torah of the servant not Moses so even
Isaiah prepared his people for a new law
given by a servant from God empowered by
the spirit and that's the law everyone
must cling to and hope in read it Isaiah
42 veres 1
and4 okay um verse one behold my servant
whom I uphold my elect in whom my soul
delighted I'm reading the King James
vers don't worry brother King
King all right um behold my servant whom
I uphold my elect in whom my soul
delighted I have put my spirit upon him
he shall bring forth judgment to the
Gentiles he shall not cry nor lift up
nor cause his voice to be heard in the
street a bruised Reed shall he not break
and the smoking Flex shall he not quench
he shall bring forth Judgment of Truth
he shall not fail nor be discouraged
till he have said judgment in the earth
and the SS shall wait for his law whose
law his law the Isles the Nations the
Gentiles will wait for his
law whose law will they trust in whose
law will they cling to whose law will
they
obey his law and who is
his uh Christ the servant Christ not
Moses right right and the Hebrew word
for law is Torah let me get it for you
it says they will trust in his
Torah let me get it for you hold on you
can see it so why do they selectively
quote versus out of context and ignore
what a book or author or Prophet Apostle
says in the entire context of the
writing here you go here it is you can
see let me give you guys the link go see
if it says his law the servants Torah
it's the word Torah here it goes let me
send it to you okay so that's that's
easy to refute these guys when you go
guys go to that link go to that link
brother you'll see where it says and for
his law okay and then you click on the
word and you go to the root and S
strongs and it's
Torah t a yes that's transliteration of
it says do sorry about
I can't even say the
word it's the word
Tor now go and click on it and it'll
give you what the word is it's rude it's
Torah it's right there
Torah so I get you see it okay yeah I do
I see it so who Torah who Tor whose
instructions and commands the Nations
will cling to and obey the servant of
the Lord who is Jesus the
[Music]
Messiah wow okay everyone got it now
even you guys listening you understood
the answer to this question because it's
going to help you understand
relationship of the law of Moses and the
law of the Lord Jesus Christ